[Musica]
quando avevo 14 anni ho fatto la mia
prima cosa illegale
ho comprato un pacchetto di sigarette ne
ho presa una
e la fumata mio padre ai tempi era il
capo della squadra mobile di torino
cioè pensateci bene io sono cresciuto
con un poliziotto dentro casa questo
vuol dire che non potevo fare niente
senza che lui lo vedesse o lo sapesse
allora doveva nascondere le prove quindi
ho preso uno spazzolino mi sono lavato i
denti alla fontanella sono tornato a
casa ho buttato i vestiti
nell'inceneritore
mio padre entra in casa mi guarda un
momento di silenzio una gocciolina hai
fumato
new york o la testa di vetro
da lì è nato un people's di 40 minuti
sul perché per come non si dovesse
sfumare e cena anche fatta a convincermi
per un po a non fumare
ora se noi mettiamo la mia triste storia
di criminale fallito
dentro categorie e otteniamo due la
prima è acquisizione di dati cioè come
faceva mio padre a sapere che avevo
fumato beh lui aveva fatto tantissimi
corsi sul comportamento umano sapeva
leggere le espressioni della faccia
sapeva riconoscere le inclinazioni della
voce sapeva capire che cosa voleva dire
la goccioline di sudore i segnali di
nervosismo e poi conosceva me ei miei
precedenti penali dentro casa la seconda
categoria invece è persuasione cioè
tentare di far cambiare un comportamento
a qualcuno o un'idea e teoricamente
questo dovrebbe avvenire senza violenza
o minaccia ora a qualcuno negli anni 90
a un gruppo di ricercatori di stanford
capitanati da fox è venuto in mente di
mettere mio padre cioè una persona con
le caratteristiche di mio padre
dentro un computer ottenendo così una
tecnologia persuasiva perché all'inizio
nata per cose buonissime cioè per
l'ambiente ad esempio
portarci a comportarci meglio oppure per
la salute io voglio dimagrire e c'è un
app che mi ricorda che cosa devo fare è
eccezionale poi si è evoluta la
tecnologia e si sono evolute ovviamente
le idee perché la tecnologia è uno
strumento era cominciato a essere stato
applicato per marketing e poi per
neuromarketing e poi per vendere un
prodotto specifico che è l'attenzione
delle persone perché più si riesce a
coinvolgere le persone all'interno di
una piattaforma più è possibile
trasmetterli dei messaggi più ti conosco
più è facile trasmetterti un messaggio
ora possiamo immaginarci la tecnologia
persuasiva come una specie di 007 ed
essendo 007 si deve travestire da
qualche cosa va in borghese e si
traveste da oggetto cioè ogni volta che
noi prendiamo il nostro cellulare e
diciamo di sì a accedi alla telecamera
dacia di al microfono scateniamo 007 che
acquisisce i nostri dati ma non solo
quando mandiamo i messaggi i messaggi
sono dati vengono conservati da qualche
parte questo è un po come mamma e papà
che ci leggono il diario quando siamo
piccolini
lo fanno anche i vestiti il resto ci
sono anche i vestiti smart i pantaloni
da yoga che ti mettono nella posizione
corretta corrispondente a quello
dell'app
ora cosa raccoglie dati tanti e infatti
si chiamano big data
lo può fare ovunque in qualunque parte
del mondo non si stanca mai
l'intelligenza artificiale parla tutte
le lingue e ci segue in dei posti in cui
normalmente
noi non accettiamo le persone che è che
di voi che non va al bagno col telefono
ora quando noi firmiamo il foglio
privacy
normalmente un po ossessiva della
privacy fammi vedere oppure dammi quella
roba perché pensiamo che quello che sa è
solamente nome cognome indirizzo codice
fiscale e al massimo mi arriva un po di
pubblicità al massimo un po di spam
al massimo lamento nello spam e non è
esattamente così a un po come se
qualcuno ci mettesse le mani nella
nostra testolina diventa
e cominciasse a ravanare dentro
che cosa vuole sapere è visto che vuole
persuadere vuole sapere delle cose che
servono per persuadere aristotele ci
dice che la persuasione composta da tre
elementi il primo è l'ethos cioè
l'autorità di chi parla io sono tuo
padre è più facile convincere se siamo
un'autorità per qualcuno sapere chi è
un'autorità per qualcuno vuol dire avere
una prima strada per convincere la
seconda è il logos cioè la logicità del
discorso il pips di 40 minuti di mio
padre nuovamente per convincere qualcuno
logicamente devo dargli le informazioni
in un modo che per quella persona sia
comprensibile sapendo un po come pensa
cosa gli piace cosa sa è il verso il
pathos cioè la relazione emozionale tra
chi parla e chi ascolta ora 007 vuole
sapere delle cose specifiche e la prima
sono i filtri cognitivi cioè come
facciamo noi a immagazzinare le
informazioni come vediamo la realtà non
tutti vedono la realtà nello stesso modo
ad esempio in questa fotografia a
qualcuno vede la fotografia qualcuno
vedi il colore qualcuno vede due ananas
qualcuno vede due ananas molto diversi
qualcuno si focalizza sul fatto che la
riga estorta e si trova nel posto
sbagliato della fotografia filtri
cognitivi il secondo elemento
fondamentale che si sono due modi per
processare le informazioni
il primo è la rotta centrale cioè
ragionare il pozzo di mio padre
solo che a ragionare comporta tantissima
fatica e le persone normalmente vanno
risparmio energetico cioè non vogliono
fare sforzo
il secondo invece la via periferica cioè
una forma di collegamento con un
cervello primordiale viene chiamato che
bypassa il ragionamento e prende le
decisioni
noi diremmo di pancia distinto viene
fatto attraverso due modi il primo sono
le emozioni e l'altro i byas cognitivi
le emozioni perché perché quando noi ci
troviamo in un picco emozionale
come molto felice molto tristi e molto
piu facile darci qualcosa a venderci
qualcosa farci cambiare idea ma non solo
se io so che cosa emoziona qualcuno cosa
ti emoziona il rombo del motore perché
ti senti potente all idea di libertà nel
guidare la tua macchina l'altro sono i
buyers cognitivi cioè delle forme di
automatismo dei riflessi automatici che
impediscono il pensiero razionale ed
elaborato ce ne parla cialdini
moltissimo che uno psicologo
statunitense in un libro che si chiama
le armi della persuasione ad esempio è
l'ultimo lo fanno perché è l'ultimo
questo è il motivo per cui amazon scrive
sempre
mancano tre pezzi o per cui ci arrivano
le pubblicità con scritto solo per oggi
non è vero che solo per oggi ma è un
automatismo oppure lo fanno tutti
consenso sociale ma come non hai
facebook coerenza con noi stessi il tuo
post costato un anno fa ha fatto 100
like riposta lo ok ora conoscendo queste
informazioni un intelligenza artificiale
riesce a fare una cosa che è un calcolo
statistico prognostico e continuare ad
imparare sulla base dei dati che escono
rimettendoli come informazioni spingendo
goccia dopo goccia delle idee
all'interno della nostra testa ogni
tanto si mette una goccia di un colore
diverso
la professoressa young dell'università
di birmingham ha identificato questo
concetto ai tuoi annunci che in italiano
suona un po come super spintarella una
super spintarella non è nient'altro che
una forma di configurazione di qualcosa
per farci andare verso una direzione
questo succede su base statistica
all'inizio
cioè se all'interno del menu c'è la
prima scelta e dalla più facile sarà più
facile che io faccia la prima scelta ma
cosa c'è fuori dal menu oppure mettere
le cose in un punto della pagina oppure
in un altro
oppure le armi della persuasione di
cialdini delle cose che funzionano un po
con tutti ma poi l'intelligenza
artificiale mi impara cioè interagisce
con me mi profila e riesce a imparare
cosa piace a stefano non ho un maschio
bianco di 43 anni a stefano che vive a
torino e fa l'avvocato
cosa gli piace la differenza è questa un
messaggio generico è guida piano
potresti uccidere un bambino un
messaggio profilato invece è un video
deep fake quindi con la faccia
modificata di mio figlio che viene
investito da una macchina guida piano
potresti investire un bambino per
evitare di farlo compra questo sistema
frenante fan super spintarella questo
raggiunto delle dimensioni un po
sconvolgenti e ad esempio nel 2012 la
corioni university ha fatto un
esperimento su 700mila utenti facebook a
metà sono stati dati solo notizie
positive sulla news feed per una
settimana a metà solo notizie negative
alla fine della settimana che aveva più
notizie positive costava più cose
positive
chi le aveva più negative le postava più
negative e le emozioni sono il veicolo
attraverso il pic per vendere dei beni o
delle idee a super spintarella ancora
peggio è successo con lo scandalo che è
venuto alla luce nel 2018 di cambridge
analitica c'è una società che analizzava
dati e ha preso i dati di milioni di
utenti ea profilati le mandato dei
messaggi personalizzati per spingerli a
votare per determinati candidati a
qualcuno arrivava i tuoi tre amici
l'hanno già fatto consenso sociale a
qualcun'altro arrivava fallo per la
patria coerenza con te stesso e con le
tue idee plum super spintarella
ora se questo è esplicito cioè di viene
detto io di psicanalisi per farti
perdere peso grazie
sono contento venga io giuro vorrei in
ogni momento
questa è la massima espressione della
democrazia mettiamo in condivisione
tutto quello che possiamo per riuscire a
migliorare ambiente sicurezza
quello che vogliamo
esplicito e positivo perfetto ma se
invece il mio telefono i miei vestiti
mip si canalizzano mentre mi trovo al
bagno io non ho dato il consenso a
questo non voglio essere psicanalizzato
mentre mi trovo al bagno
non voglio proprio essere psicanalizzato
se non lo so e soprattutto se è fatto
per un fine negativo
questo a una deriva incredibilmente
pericolosa perché questo è una deriva
totalitaristica questo è 1984 di orwell
che diventa vero cioè un romanzo che
parla di un futuro distopico in cui il
grande fratello ci guarda ci osserva e
la psicopolizia c entra nel cervello per
farci avere il bie pensiero diventa
reale
ora potrebbe sembrare distante troppo
più o meno in cina e in corso un
esperimento sociale per il ranking delle
persone sulla base del loro
comportamento
sulla base del loro comportamento nella
vita di tutti i giorni e sulla base del
loro comportamento online cioè vengono
dati i punti come nei hunger games
se ti comporti bene puoi accedere a dei
beni e dei servizi
se ti comporti male il mutuo non te lo
do ora questo è terrorizzante ed essendo
terrorizzante dovremmo ricordarci che è
frutto del nostro potere e il potere
appartiene al popolo ed è in mano al
popolo in questo caso è esattamente in
mano al popolo cioè qui dentro
basterebbe leggere a che cosa diamo il
consenso togliere quello a cui non
dovremmo dare il consenso o togliamo
l'accesso alla telecamera al microfono
dopo che ho visto come sarò tra
vent'anni o come sarò dell'altro sesso
magari la disinstallo o la chiudo o mi
ricordo di chiudere le varie app perché
fin quando sono aperte possono accedere
a telecamera e microfono
ora quello che io ho appena fatto è un
discorso persuasivo
ci sono tutti gli elementi c'è l'ethos
ho fatto riferimento della gente famosa
aristotele fong poi
c'è il discorso la logicità il logos ho
spiegato dei concetti fatto degli esempi
e c'è un intento persuasivo specifico
cioè conosci quello che può succedere
controlla quello che puoi e spegne tutto
quello che non ti serve perché il potere
in mano tua e teoricamente c'è anche il
pathos perché ci sono delle immagini ci
sono delle storie e c'è il ricorso al
1984 che dovrebbe generare terrore paura
e quindi spingere a ragionare
ad accendere tutti la testa e agire di
conseguenza riprendendosi il potere che
in nostra mano però io non vi conosco e
quindi procede su base statistica potete
essere convinti oppure no e se non
dovesse servire non resterà che
scatenare nei vostri telefoni di 007 e
questa è un'idea che vale la pena di
condividere